THIS GAME... is made by Lixian
Yes! The very same animator of some of your favorite animations on this channel.
And just a great all-around guy, and I wanted to play this game because he just released it.
It's his very first game. (*good job Lixian*) And I even play tested it a little bit, and it was very good.
It's his very first game. (*good job Lixian!!*) And I even play tested it a little bit, and it was very [2x] good.
It's his very first game. (*good job Lixian*) And I even play tested it a little bit, and it was very [3x] good.
It's his very first game. (*good job Lixian*) And I even play tested it a little bit, and it was very [4x] good.
It's his very first game. (*good job Lixian*) And I even play tested it a little bit, and it was very [5x] good.
So I'm gonna play it for you here. I'm also gonna provide a link down in the description. If you want, you can go buy it for yourself.
It's only 3$, and it goes to support a cool guy by the name of (*OUR LORD OF ANIMATORS*) Lixian!
So let me show you how it goes before we do any of that.
So it's a lot like your typical shmup (shoot 'em up, subgenre of shooting games that Mark enjoys and is surprisingly good at)
Which I like very much! Hang on... Wait-no... hang on! Hang on! I'm not ready! I wasn't ready! Hang on!
So this is the main shmup patoot (*In other words, bullet-hell stage*) of it you got your power-schmups (*Power-ups*)
Hang on! *Sudden Shriek*
There we go! Okay!
I'm good!
So you got your main shmups (*Pieces of Shits*) Got your dudes here! These dudes ain't gonna hurt your-- Your ship
His mother is shielded. Mother is the ship that you're escorting to try to save Earth by getting supplies down.
So your shooty
So your shooty [2x]
So your shooty [2x] Oh!
So your shooty [3x] Oh!
So your shooty [4x] Oh!
So your shooty [5x] Oh!
So your shooty [6x] Oh!
I think I get too close. You got to SHIELD BLAST!!
That's how you do it.
So that's the trick right? You can't be on both sides of the screen at once unless you're really good like me.
So you got to do what you got to do?
And you gotta-- You gotta use your "SHIELD BLAST!!" which is the name of the game, right?
So the "SHIELD BLAST!!" is like the unique mechanic of this game
And you got to use it and time it correctly so that you can get these assholes...
Away from your ship. No--Ship! I screwed that--Ow! I screwed that up, but don't worry about it.
Aye aye aye [x2]
And eventually, you get enough money to do upgrades on the next screen around. I may actually get to the end of this!
On this round, which just goes to show that I played it a bit before...
Hey, hey you ugly ya out here. Those. Six is 10 levels in each one. I know what do an amazingly
Let's just I use it of
SHIP!
Oh ship!, I think--actually these are better than not to hit...
Oh ship! [2x], I think actually these are better than not to hit?...
Maybe?
Maybe? Yeah?
Maybe? Yeah? Eh?
*Mark's concentration*
*Mark's concentration.*
*Mark's concentration..*
*Mark's concentration...*
*Mark's concentration... INTENSIFIES!!*
Eh?
Eh? Eh?
Eh? Eh? Eeaaughhh?
God oh god. I've got oh no no mother. I'm sorry mom. Oh. No. I'm sorry. I'm sorry. I'm sorry mom
In Maine too - I ladybugs, so you can't let your your mother ship Scott shields
And you've got only a limited amount of health that I'm about to run out of hey
Go back to bug's life
Yeah, yeah all right all right all right all right all right? Oh God lovely
I'm doing shock. Oh god. Of course I missed the goddamn upgrade because I'm a fricking idiot of course I do uh yeah. Yeah, no
Don't fall apart now
Three L's and no upgrades because I'm a damn douche, but that's okay
It's AMA expert at the shield blast ability level nine I can make it first try baby first try
I'm gonna make it. I'm gonna make it. I'm not gonna make it ma
Shit yes-yes-yes-yes-yes-yes-yes-yes
Ow fine it's fine fine fine and dandy
Yee
fine
surprisingly were
Muffled I'm the first try I've got three elf I can do this. I can't believe it
I can do this I can do this oh
shit
Okay
Okay, okay, okay, yes rapid-fire. Yes, oh
this your blast
She'll blast
Yes
Oh
No
Please please I can't be in both Sanji ones. Oh boy. Oh boy. Oh boy, please please, babe
Chip blasted at the ass. She'll blows aah
Frank look at that bleep. Oh please. I'm sure oh shit. I forgot that was a boss oh
No
No, no, I can do this. I got to elf that's all I need baby
Oh fuck didn't that just look like that looks so like licks in style. I love it. All right you asked
It's fine. It's fine. It's fine. It's a bunch of leaves it ain't nothing
It ain't nothing to nobody oh
Shit I keep missing all the upgrades I'm never gonna get this guy down. I can't even do any damage to him
Got it got it nailing your bill. Yeah. Oh, yeah, what you gonna. Do oh, yeah, I'm doing I'm dodging yeah
Oh got the bullets out
oh
Shit oh shit. Oh god damn it one out. No. I'm not fucking it up now
I'm gonna go the fucking dastar than my help. There was a help there. I needed
Yes, yes get out, okay, yes yes yes yes yes yes, yes, Oh
See the shield blast can also do your bullets out of the way, which chef forgot in the beginning phases of this fight
You'll never get there we go there. We go there. We go get the tablet no
No, okay, I'm fine there goes health shit shitty tosser yes
Yes, yes, yes. Yes. Yes. Yes. Yes. Yes. Yes yes yes. Yes, Oh
God why why every frickin time I'll get it okay. I got it. I don't know how I got that but I got it
Got it got it
Oh, yeah got it. Yes. Yes, shit. Well can't use this now. That's unfortunate
Yes, yes yes
Josh josh Josh
Josh, Josh. Yes. Yes. Yes. Yes yes, yes
Yes, yes no no no no no. No yes. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah, yeah, no no yeah
I
Didn't mean that, but I went for it cuz I'm a baller pusher ow
I'm a shot-caller I get stabbed in the neck
But I don't really want to be come on come on come on come on. Yes. Yes, yes, no
III
And
Chubowski, yeah, fuck you first try I'm the best. I'm the greatest I did it. I'm getting that hell
Yeah, get rekt. It's a Lloyd. I got you mission accomplished. Hell. Yeah well
That's just one of three phases now. I got a lot of look. I got a lot of money
I got a lot of money the mornings mine
So I'm gonna go in and I'm gonna show you the diversity that happens in the enemies here
they do get
They do get harder because they have different
Qualities throughout the levels they got a lot of really clever mechanics here licks in did a good job planning this out
And just cuz I'm good at it doesn't mean that it's easy I just happen to like shmups
Oh, you death shrooms get out of there
See this is where if it gets dicey I can use the shield blast get them out of the hole
Get him out of the word
Booya
Hahahahaha, hey ooh
Where it gets dicey, er ye be Oh No
The shield blasts if I didn't properly describe it it's the little white pulse that comes out of the bottom
I am timing that and it's important hence. Why the game is called shield blast
Of Seavey's assholes these assholes here. Yeah nice teaching me about it looks seem good teaching
Level no no no if you kill them before they go ahead and make it a little easier on you
No, yeah, there we go
No I missed Ellen I miss em too, cuz I'm an asshole
I'm missing all of you oh, no oh no oh no
Because once they're invincible the only way to get them is with the shield blastin if you just happen to have shield blast on cooldown
I mean they regenerate pretty ah come on
They regenerate pretty quickly. Oh, I wasn't paying attention. I wasn't paying a tution there. We go boy. Oh boy
Maybe I can get both levels down to one try they're gonna do the whole game without dying
I haven't actually beaten the third level have not the third phase whatever it is
Oh, no miss me miss me by that much dillweeds
Got him okay, level seven I'm doing it wonderfully I'm doing amazing. No you got
barely miss that guy
No come on
I'm missing all of them. I am so boned
ow
Why did I get hit? Why did I let myself get head?
Talk shit get hit. Ha ha oh
Shit, hooah. Oh shit go ah okay. It's fine. No. I don't like those cats those guys
Oh No Oh, No
Wow exploding booms oh
Okay, oh god. Oh god. This is terrible. Oh this horse
So I gotta like double make sure I'm actually in the same spot when they die
Girls, I'll be the one that dies right here comes the big blasters
Shit Oh God Oh God things are going wrong things are going so very wrong how in
There we go oh shit, okay, well this bad. Oh boy. Oh boy. Oh boy. Oh, boy
One live laughs
Okay there we go we're fine ah
how do
The Hecky heck did I survive that I don't know
Oh God. Oh god well there goes my shields, okay well
Well no menu, let's come menu
Boy, oh, but you can see
You can see
how this game's super fun so the point is you're not supposed to win right away unless you're like super skilled and I'm not the
Most skilled, but I'm pretty good, but this has been shield blessed. This is awesome. I love it
It's a simple concept, but he put a lot of his own spin on it
And I just got a like applauding for the effort
He put this out its out available on game tool right now links in the description check it out for yourself
I really want to support licks in and I hope you guys to
Play the game for yourself and see if you like it let him know anything you can do to improve
So thank you everybody so much for watching check out this game too the link in the description below
Let me know what you think down in the comments and as always I will see you in the next video. Bye